un vestido de yves al nuevo junto al
cuadro de pablo picasso que lo inspiró
sanz luego fue uno de los primeros en
llevar el museo a la pasarela a los 29
años el diseñador francés confecciona un
vestido que revolucionó la moda dando
vida a una de las composiciones de la
línea del artista holandés piet mondrian
[Música]
y añade una dimensión a la obra de
mondrian porque da movimiento a formas
que fueron creadas para ser estáticas y
ese es realmente el aspecto visionario
de lo que hizo
vestidos con los diseños de sandú o las
personas dan vida a las obras de arte
los bordados confieren a esta chaqueta
con forma de girasol la textura
empastada típica de la obra de van gogh
mientras que el estilo pixelado de este
cuadro de alan ya que se convierte en
una serie de patrones geométricos
el arte europeo no fue la única
inspiración de sant luego a finales de
los años 60 en sus viajes a marruecos
descubrió colores vivos y materiales
como los collares de madera y la rafia y
salió un diseño este vestido en 1967
para la colección bambara que rindió
homenaje al arte africana vemos que la
modernidad es esencial para ello y la
encontró en el arte africano una mezcla
de tradición y líneas elegantes y
atemporal
sanz luego también era conocido por sus
siluetas largas y andróginas el mismo
era un hábil ilustrador la casa que
compartía con su marido pierre marie era
su propio mini museo lleno de obras que
habían coleccionado juntos saludo deja
un legado de una estética duradera la
cual consideraba más importante que la
moda
si paramos
lo que importa es el estilo no la moda
porque la moda pasa pero el estilo
perdura
pero este verano
la obra de ibsen logo ha influenciado en
generaciones de diseñadores que siguen
con jugando su moda con una alta dosis
de arte